- Hi, welcome everyone.
So that they have a very special
video plan for you today.
When, a couple of days ago
asked on my Instagram account
whether you would be interested
to see a video like that
I go out on overwhelmingly
positive response.
I believe never did I get
as many people saying,
"Yes please make this video."
And specifically today,
I'm going to show you how
I create a PowerPoint presentation.
I will let you look over my shoulders
how I use PowerPoint for myself
and I will also share my thought process
why I structure pages the way I do,
how I think about structuring
elements on a page.
So all of this will be
included in this video,
and yes I will give for the opportunity
to also download the
sample slides in the end,
there's a donut link in
the video description,
I can sign up and the receive the files.
So when I come to
another coffee break here
on my channel Firm Learning,
my name is Heinrich,
I'm a former McKinsey consultant
and on my channel I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
Now in the video, I
wanna find a good balance
of really showing you what I'm doing
and why I'm doing it in detail
but also speeding up some sections
where I'm just doing things
that is not that interesting.
So I hope you will like it.
And I will also try to not
use that many shortcuts
to make it easier to follow.
I might do a video
specifically on short cuts
at some point in the future,
but frankly, I'm not even using
that many shortcuts in PowerPoint,
for sure there are some that
are really hard for you,
but this will not be the focus for today.
So without further ado, let's get into it.
So before this video, I asked myself,
"Okay what presentation
cannot really show you?"
Because for these reasons,
I cannot really guide you
through an extra presentation
that I did for work.
So I thought, okay let me
show you a presentation
that I potentially would do
maybe for a sponsorship partner
of this channel.
So as a YouTuber, sometimes
people approach me
and ask me if they can do
a collaboration with me,
so let's imagine I'd
like to pitch my channel,
Firm Learning, to such a partner
and how such a little
pitch deck could look like.
And indeed the first thing
that I usually like to do
is to come up with the storyline
and specifically to come
up with the action titles
of the presentation.
So the titles that we put
here in the beginning.
They have no idea what an action title
is actually created a
whole video about that.
I will link it somewhere above.
So have a look at that
really a fundamental concept,
but let's start it.
I'd say first page was always a nice page
but introduce myself and the agendas.
So I could write something like this.
Firm Learning is an educational video
consulting channel on social media.
It's creator is Heinrich
Rusche, a former MBB consultant,
So this will potentially
be a good first slide
where I then insert the contents.
And the data often and also like
to already make some
bullets what I will include,
so I could for instance, show my audience
and also an introduction of who I am.
Okay, what could be next?
And here, I think it's good
to provide a little overview
of how the content looks like
that I create here on my Firm
Learning YouTube channel.
So here we could write
something like this.
All right, so this is
not going to be a page
where I indeed talk about
some things that I'm doing.
So potentially, an overview
of Firm Learning videos.
That I could then be showing your,
to this potential client of mine.
Okay next, what would
do you as the next page
in such a story?
And let's imagine that already
to the pilot for this client
where I tested out a, the
campaign just to prove the value.
So I could write something like this
Firm Learning pilots.
So this could be now a little chart
where show exactly what the
very look that I provided
and some conclusions from that.
Now probably an overview of the pricing,
the different contents that I
could offer would be helpful.
So let's create a, such an overview
for a collaboration in 2020,
the following packages go to be offered
and then let's end with
some contact information
that I provide for them
to be able to contact me.
And again, this will be a
rather short little presentation
of course, he will probably
flesh this out a bit more
really recreate such a deck,
but I trust that this will
provide a little overview
of all of this looks.
So let's start with the first one,
actually, let's start with the title page,
and you're just inserted a
more or less random stock photo
that shows a boardroom setting
but let's start here with the title.
So let's call it Firm Learning
Collaboration Proposal.
And then often he has a subtitle,
you can include something
like the month or the date
and then also whatever
document potentially
there's a for instance,
discussion document.
So let's not start by filling this page.
So one of the most fundamental
principles of slide design
that really make your life so much easier
is the principle: every page is a table.
Every page or slide that
you create in PowerPoint
is a table.
So always think about it like a table
where you structure information
in columns and in rows.
So here in deep, we have
two types of elements
that we wanna include here.
First, some information on the audience
and then some information
on myself, right?
Where I'm introducing myself as a creator.
And what I like to use when
I do these kinds of things
are always little column headers.
Because indeed we could not
structure those as the table
we're probably in the
left side of the page
is about the audience,
so the left column if
you wanna put it this way
is the audience and then the right column,
the right side of the
page is the introduction.
And I always like to use
an element like this.
I know, copied it over
from another document.
This is pretty much just a text element
and this is just a line.
And then if you do this together
you can also potentially group it.
I use Control + G as a
shortcut as such an element.
So yeah, let's call this audience,
and let's call this for the
right-hand side, introduction.
So this is now the basic structure
that you want your page to take.
And all the good next step
is always to think about
how do I not further structure
these two columns, these two sides?
So let's start with the audience.
And you're really we want to show
what the audience of Firm
l]Learning looks like, right?
So how is it structured?
And your good first straightforward step
might be just to show the
different social media channels
that I have.
And again, if you remind yourself
that every page has a table
no here the natural step
the natural tendency
that you would want to lean to
is now need to structured as rows, right?
If you have no different elements
that you wanna show within such a column,
you use rows for that.
So let's not start by creating rows
for the different social
media channels that I have.
So let's start here with first YouTube.
This is of course the
largest channel that I use.
The next, we might have Instagram,
and I'll let me show you a little shortcut
because if you press Shift + Control
and then move an element
it creates a copy and it
keeps the axis fixed, right?
So doesn't matter if you go up
or down or he left and right,
it keeps it fixed, that creates
it on the same level, right?
This is of course extremely
helpful for things like that.
So again, I'm coping this
over YouTube, Instagram,
I have Firm Learning newsletter
and I have linkedIn.
I'd say these are my main channels.
And again with these things
that always simplifies your life
so much if you make sure
that all the elements
always have the same width,
because this will help
you to keep the whole page
much more organized.
You can not just drag it
a little bit like this
and it will show you later
why this is so important.
Now this seems to have font size 18.
Let's make it a little bit smaller,
let's make it font size 16.
You, one basic rule of slide writing
is to make sure that
all the texts elements
all the elements in one page
with the exception being the
action title and the footnote
have the same font size, right?
So let's make sure that this is the case.
Okay, now we take these four channels.
We align them here to the left,
I always like to use these
little alignment buttons.
What you can see is here that
I drag the quick access bar.
From the top here, where it's usually
here now to this lower element,
because this not reduces the distance
from my mouse to get there
and this really makes life easier for me.
So what I did is now highlighted
this, highlighted this,
then clicked here this align left button
to make it all on the same playing field.
And in detail now another
little rule of slight writing,
so always what you like to
do is think about the page
to be like a drawing place, right?
Where you read on the
boundaries of the actual title
and the boundaries of the page.
So you want to make sure for
it to have proper margins
that nothing goes to the
left of the action title,
that nothing goes beyond that.
So this is pretty an
imaginary little boundary,
and then the same is
through you to the right
where usually you like
to end the action title
together here with the footnote
and then nothing is
supposed to be further right
at the near the demarcation that exists
by the right boundary of this plage.
Now let's further think of
how we can structure it.
And did not let's further desegregate
this left part into two
types of information.
So the first is the platform,
this is now what we already did here,
but then we also want to
include a second column
and you know added the same copying trick
that I showed you with the shortcut
where I talk about the
Firm Learning audience
and this is then supposed to
give us the audience size.
And here in D on YouTube,
I have 85,000 subscribers.
So this is pretty much my audience
that I currently have at this very moment.
Now let's further style the section.
So I'd like to do to
have the column headers
in bold and black
but then if I want to
focus on any other elements
within the columns, I like to bold them,
but then not in black,
but personally I like
to use dark blue, right?
So this creates a little
hierarchy among the elements
because of course, black
has darker than dark blue,
you, of course you could know,
highlight these numbers again
make sure to make them blue
just to form this in a proper way.
Now you could further style it differently
by increasing all the
font sizes of the numbers.
So that's, for instance, if
we use a two font size 40,
so this is of course
now a little deviation
from the rule that I told you
that everything needs
to look exactly the same
in terms of font size,
but of course sometimes
little deviations like this
are allowed if it improves
the overall look and feel,
even though I would
encourage you to follow this
rather strictly for most cases.
So not only do the thing that you can do
to further improve the
look and feel of this page
is to include little
icons for these platforms.
So I did a video on
this topic in the past,
I will also include it
somewhere above here.
They are also recommended your service
that also personally
use to really draw icons
because of course, if you
just download then somewhere
in the Google picture search
they will often have a
problem with copyright.
But if you use the service simple slides
you can have access to
large library of icons
all of them are for you copyright free
if you have the subscription
you can also use it
for commercial purposes, so I
can very much recommend this,
if you're interested to try
out simple slides for yourself
there's a link to that in the
video description this way.
So in the meantime already
selected a couple of icons
that I took from simple
slides, they also have icons
for the different social media platforms.
So I'm just copying that in here.
Of course, these look a bit
weird in terms of the color.
Yellow would also be great to have,
this dark blue type of look
and this is exactly what
we will get us here.
So let's not include them a bit
and now it's great to
potentially insert them
to the left of your slides.
So let's move this a
little bit to the right
let's move this to the right as well.
And now we have some space here
where we can include these little icons.
So now another little thing
to further tidy all this up
is to use separation lines.
So this is also very,
very common element to use
and to do this pretty much
include a line like this.
I often like to form
this and some light gray
and then also some dashes
here that you can use.
Again here make sure
that this properly starts
here to the left and then
also ends you to the right
of this element,
and then with the same trick
that I showed you earlier
you can copy this over here.
Now if you're this far
you can then group the different elements.
You drag this to the bottom
where you want to start it all,
you drag this to the top where
you want to let this start
then you highlight this potential
so here to have an equally
spaced out a line of this way
and then it's properly
and evenly distributed.
So let's now move here to the left side,
so to the introduction parts
so first now it would be great
also visually separate this
a little bit more from the
right side of the slide.
So for that we can add here another line
for such a separation line
then it makes sense to us to make it
a solid line maybe increase
the weight a little bit more.
And now make sure that this
nicely ends to the right
where I showed you here to
the end of the footnote.
And now you can use some
space to include some text
about myself.
So we could for instance, call this
Meet the creator.
So pretty much meet me as
the creator of Firm Learning
and then to further leverage on this.
So what could make sense
in such a situation
is to start by for
instance, including a photo,
you just copied over a photo of myself
of course, the introduce myself
and then maybe you're on the right
you might want to include some texts.
So for instance, my name with
career and consulting content.
Something like this is
what you could include.
Then again, you highlight this,
you make it dark blue to bold it
and then you center it or line it here.
So this could be, you know this element,
and there then maybe here
in some bullets below
I'd like to include some information
about myself also in
the sense of a mini CV,
a mini curriculum vitae.
So just a couple of things
that you could include here, right?
Can move this up a little bit,
potentially move this a little bit down,
maybe you not realize
that it would be nicer
to we land this more through the bottom
to have a more evenly spaced out,
of course, all of this could be done now.
And now it's also always a great idea
to potentially bold a couple
of key pieces of information
that you would like to include, okay?
So this could be no first page
that you could use in such a deck.
So let's not do the second page
and here, what I'd just like
to show is a very basic page
where I show different
examples of thumbnails
of my YouTube videos, just
to give the impression
of what my topic is all about
what my videos are like.
So indeed, if you do something like this
that it makes sense to also
include a little header.
So I will include a little
head out as this saying
Exemplary Firm Learning content,
selected YouTube thumbnails, right?
And again, here, what I like to do
is whenever I have a
little extra information,
I like to unload it and then
use here a little gray color
to just make it look nice
but this is my personal preference
other people might use different titles.
Now let's insert a couple of pictures
of thumbnails of my videos.
So here we go, and indeed now,
as always with these things,
alignment is important
so these are now 12 pictures.
So that's roughly align them in three rows
with four columns each.
So something like this, but now of course
we'd need to be properly
aligned to the boundaries
so here to the left here to the right
now the rows to each other.
What then you can do, if
you do something like this
is always to include, for instance
a little picture border
to make it look properly.
But then I'd say this really is a good
proper page that you can very
well use for such a purpose.
Now, next page.
And here you remember that we wanted
to show some resides of a pilot
that I did maybe in the past
with this specific client.
So the basic structure that you can follow
when you work like this,
when you work with numbers
and create a chart
is that to the left, you have
a column with exactly that.
So the chart and then to the right,
you have a color with some implications,
some conclusions that you wanna make.
So for us, all we do is that
as always we include some
heteros for these columns.
So this all be for the chart
where we say sources of new users,
numbers of users indicated by client
and then to the right,
you potentially write something like,
yeah let's just call
it conclusions, right?
And now we want to include charts,
I will now use things say,
which is a plug in for PowerPoint.
It's a plugin very
widely and commonly used
by consulting firms, most
large consulting firms use it
but also corporate firms use it
it's really great to create charts,
but of course you can do these things
with the bid in PowerPoint
chart creation tools as well.
So I will spare you the
details of our executive need
to work with things sell are created here,
such a very, very basic thing,
say waterfall chart where we say,
okay, total new clients
than what did Firm Learning
contribute as a source?
What came from paid Facebook Ads
and what came from other channels?
And here is just what I wanna say was
that you I need to be very, very careful
and rather sparse with the color.
So don't really use lots of colors
don't make it super powerful.
You just go to make it
for instance, on a gray
and then I just did this in
dark blue just to emphasize
what was coming from my channel
what was coming from Firm Learning.
Now next, you can continue
by adding some information
and some conclusion some insights
that you are drawing from all of this.
So let justice always copy
all over this text field.
Let's fix your, the font size of font 16,
and now we can insert some text.
So now in order for you
not needing to just watch me type a lot,
I adjust the copy or the text over
with a couple of information here
and this is now indeed
what we will use for this.
Let's now maybe space it
out a little bit better.
But now here we have such a page
where we indeed show
a chart of the resides
and then provide some
conclusions and insights
that we are drawing from that.
Let's not do this page,
where indeed I wanna talk about
the different service
packages that we could offer,
what these would include
and then also some price tags in the end.
So let's imagine
that we have three
different service packages
that we would be willing to offer.
And here again, in the table format
if you have three different elements
you can make sure to organize
them in three columns.
So let's just imagine
we call them level one,
the core package, intermediate package
and the advanced package.
So we created these headers for you,
so you see, these are just
the very basic same header
that we were already using.
And then here in the rows, what
do we put here in the rows?
And you know, one mistake
that many people are doing
is on such an instance, just
to create a page like this
include some bullets like this,
and then just create a long list
of different bullets, right?
So now I'll be writing something
about a long list of stuff
where you detail all
types of different things.
This always looks very, very unstructured
and not professionally.
This is what you call
the cloth line, right?
So a long close line list of
randomly unstructured bullets.
So whenever you do things like that,
think about how could
you structure the bullets
into logical groups,
into groups of elements
that were fit together.
And this is exactly
what we want to do here
and because here now we want
to describe the service package,
what we are offering you,
of course, and make sense
when you use the different
social media channels
that we are offering,
and then what we would do
in each of these packages
and then maybe in the end as the last row,
the pricing for all of this.
So in these instances, what I like to do
is to use a little boxes like this,
for instance, we could use a
light blue then as a border,
a dark blue and now in this box,
you know, organize these things, right?
And we know one box for every channel,
let's make it Arial
usually like to use Arial
as a basic font because
I believe it looks nice
and clean the most cases.
And now we do this for
the different channels
that we introduced earlier.
So YouTube, Instagram
and you just the general rule.
So what you should really notice memorize
is that whenever you have
now a set of elements
that repeat throughout the document
and your, for instance this
will be the different platforms
the different social media
channels that you use
make sure that they always
appear in the same order
as initially introduce them.
It's always super confusing
if you have a set of pages like this,
where you talk about
the different channels,
and then on the one page
it starts with YouTube
on the other page with Instagram
and then with another one,
always keep it in the same order,
this will help you to keep this organized
and clean and nice to follow.
Of course it would in
these cases also be nice
to use the same icons that you
used here on the page before.
Now, in order for you to
not see me type too much
I'll just now create a
different text boxes of bullets.
Now, of course, we could also
use separate aLliance here.
So let me copy some in here as well.
So let's now also make sure
to include some content here
in the bottom for this content
editing and production part.
And now what you could do
is include a little arrow
to make sure that this
last one is really relevant
for all the three packages, right?
So it's the same for
all these three packages
that you're offering.
So you could use an arrow like this,
maybe make it even a little bit bolder,
or now even if you make this up front,
it does look a little bit weird.
And here, what you can do is
to then include a little box
that you would just make white,
you again properly center
it here in the middle,
and then you do this to the end,
you do this to the end of this as well,
you will lie in all of this.
And now you have such a formation
which looks more or less, great.
So let's now align this properly as well
here again, you can group
these different row elements
as always something you
learned this by now.
Now it's all nicely and evenly spaced.
As you can see, this
does look a bit weird,
so something is off here.
So let's see what is causing
this and this is caused
because this is here
included in the group.
So that's ungrouped, but again,
let's group it and let's align it as well
to now fix it.
Now, finally, though, you
might want to include a line
with the commercials in the
very end to also indicate
how expensive such a package
would be to your client.
So let's just take some text here,
let's align it here to the left,
let's call this commercials
and now indeed you can include
how expansive exactly all
these different packages
are supposed to be always aligning,
aligning is the most important thing
to make it look nice and clean.
Now here you can insert
the Euro amounts in here.
I will leave it to your imagination,
what you could charge for these packages.
Again, if you have this one
finder alignment will not hurt.
And now you're good for this page.
Let's maybe move all
of this up a little bit
and then you are fine.
Now last but not least
let's include some
contact information here.
This is of course, nice
and straightforward,
this is something that you
can easily do here in the end.
So you could just do a nice page like this
not overstyle it.
So if you create something like this,
this is where you usually be
more than fine for last page
with contact information.
So this is a very basic little document
that we know jointly
created as a pitch deck,
for a typical influencer
marketing collaboration.
So for sure, this is now
not yet super polished,
there are several things
that you could not do
to further improve this.
And of course, if it would
really create such a deck
probably would expand
on it a little bit more.
You would go into more detail
of how these packages would look like.
of how your content looks like
or what you could do for the brand.
But I hope that this gives
you a good first impression
and I hope that I was successful
in really guiding you
through my thought process
and helping you to
understand how I would take
such a task if I would need
to create such a presentation.
So as always, if you have
any questions on this
do leave me a comment
in the comment section,
I would do my very best to
answer every single comment
that you write.
Also, if you wanna have the slides
that we just created for yourself,
also included a link in
the video description
where you can donate this little deck.
And please, if you took any
value out of this video at all
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the channel
to stay up to date on all my content.
You can also follow me on Instagram
my handle is @firmlearning
or you can even use letter
sign up link in the video description.
And of course also feel free
to reach out on LinkedIn.
Again, linked to that
individual description.
Now a big thanks to all the
members of Firm Learning,
you're really amazing.
My names Heinrich,
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
So looking forward to next week,
until then good weekend to all of you,
cheers this Heinrich from Firm Learning.